ferrières d'eau fera comme un forme le
personnel rapidement ambiance
particulière ce midi devant l' usine
peugeot japy de valentigney les 245
salariés viennent d'apprendre la
nouvelle
leur entreprise est placée en
redressement judiciaire pour une période
d'observation de six mois
les salaires du mois de juin qui n'avait
été versée qu'en partie vont être
débloqués
c'est plutôt un soulagement dans le sens
où c'est pas une liquidation
on sait qu'on a encore six mois devant
nous même si on espère ça ira plus vite
cette fois pour rechercher un candidat
est ce qu'on espère surtout ça ne sera
pas un candidat comme farinia quoi
quelque chose de plus solide est surtout
de plus fluide plus de plus fiables en
2018 le groupe de fonderie farinia avait
racheté l'entreprise qui fabrique des
pièces de boîtes de vitesses pour
l'industrie automobile mais depuis
l'épidémie de kobe de 19
les commandes ont chuté de plus de 60%
et des contrats importants avec bosch et
general motors ont été perdus
aujourd'hui tous espèrent qu'un
repreneur sera enfin trouvée pour
conquérir de nouveaux marchés tant qu'il
n'y a pas de repreneur vraiment sérieux
nous savons pas ce que sera demain si
finalement tout le monde retire ses
offres ben ce sera toujours au point
zéro donc la liquidation
aujourd'hui on n'espère pas en arriver
là on espère que rob vraiment des offres
sérieuses avec un vrai projet derrière
et pas des promesses comme farinia ce
nous faire que au final deux ans plus
tard nous voici là dès la semaine
prochaine deux administrateurs
judiciaires vont se rendre sur site pour
rencontrer direction et salariés et
tenter de trouver une solution pour
sauver cette pme historique à 7 heures
une offre de reprise ferme porté par
l'actuel directeur a été enregistré deux
autres industriels français se sont
aussi dits intéressés